there steve kaufman here i'm sitting by
a window
in
or near arcos de la frontera in spain
i'm sorry that i didn't provide any
summary of my
five days to fluency in prague because
on the final day i did a video interview
with yarda right by the charles bridge
but somehow i managed to lose that video
in my iphone
so we don't have that video
uh
but let's i'd like to
sort of give you my impressions of how
things went i think was a great success
uh i was in prague essentially for four
days i arrived the evening of the first
uh so i had the second third fourth
uh second third fourth and fifth four
days and then the morning of the sixth
saturday morning i flew to portugal
um i think on average i spoke about six
or seven hours of check every day i did
this basically because i was able to
arrange uh two check lessons every day
and then with all of our link members
and other people who came to the
meetup and people that i knew in the
czech republic i was able to get in a
lot of speaking like the first night we
had
dinner in a pub and we were there and i
was speaking czech
for about four or five hours so plus the
two and a half hours of lessons that i
had that was six and a half hours
um you know i can't remember now i had a
lunch where i spoke check i was invited
one of the
people who came to our meetup was a
lawyer in prague mikhail he invited me
to lunch so i spoke check there
i had dinner with zdenyak and his
girlfriend and yarda on thursday night
so we spoke check the whole evening
there
um
let's see i had dinner uh with uh jan
and gabriela they invited me to their
place which was lovely and that was
friday night and friday night i can say
that uh and gabriella can confirm this
i was there from 6 until 10 maybe
and we the entire conversation was was
in check and unlike the situation at the
pub the first night where there's
conversations flying in 10 different
directions and it's hard to hear because
of the noise
uh the evening with jan and gabriella we
were conversing i was comfortable i
missed the odd word but it was a very
pleasant experience
uh i i think my my um experiment was a
success
because the big thing was that i could
understand i could understand what i saw
about me
i could understand
if i wanted as i was able to do on a
couple of occasions strike up impromptu
conversations with people i was able to
do so i understood what they said back
to me
and this intensity of exposure and of
speaking the language certainly elevated
my check
now
and so i will in conclusion i would
recommend this approach to anyone i
would recommend staying longer than four
days which is all i had
uh i think it's better if you've got two
weeks or a month
but i would certainly recommend and and
this is something that i saw in a video
that professor argelia's made
that uh in order to take advantage of
this immersion experience you're far
better off to have a significant
background in the language before you go
and in my view
uh this sort of passive vocabulary the
ability to understand that you build up
through lots of reading and listening at
working at link for example the way i
did so that you arrive with a lot of
vocabulary that sets you up
to really take advantage of your stay
now i should say a few words in czech
and i will
but
the problem is that since leaving prague
which was kind of the high point of my
check
i've had a week
in portugal a phenomenal holiday where a
group of former canadian trade
commissioners
once every five years we gather in
europe and play golf
and uh portugal is such a lovely country
people are so friendly the food the fish
everything is so wonderful and
and i i didn't speak as much portuguese
as i would like because all of the
people who deal with a tourist industry
in portugal are absolutely fluent in
english so but nevertheless i was
exposed to portuguese
and since that period now i've been in
spain for four or five days uh my wife
and i were injured la frontera there the
english is not quite as strong so i was
able to use spanish a lot so
um
just to say that my check is now two
languages in terms of immersion two
languages removed from when i was in
prague
[Music]
uh
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
is
[Music]
[Music]
so that's just a brief little monologue
rambling on a bit in check uh yeah i'm a
little bit rusty now i've been away from
it for 15 days
uh however
i felt i was doing very well in my check
and so the goal that i set for myself a
year ago starting from scratch
that i would work very hard on my own uh
largely passive learning using link
reading listening building up my
vocabulary
so that when i
reached prague i would really be able to
take advantage now i can speak
but more than that i can also understand
i can read with gaps and so the big
problem i now have is
whether i should continue to work on
czech which i find fascinating
or i had said to myself that i would at
some point like to work on my korean
which i've left in obeying so i did some
korean about six seven years ago worked
at it for six months or so and it is
kind of low-hanging fruit to the extent
that i speak japanese and chinese so i
may end up doing a bit of a bit of um
a bit of check in a bit of korean and
yet i would like to work on improving my
spanish and portuguese at the same time
so the more languages you learn the
dilemma
always is what are you going to spend
your time on because you would like to
you know get deeper into some of these
languages and yet it's so much fun to
gain that experience with a new language
and culture so we'll see what happens
but thank you for listening and bye for
now